Turo is coming off yeah awesome you're
excited burn the dude I'm a big fan
McEnroe is here well sure well I got a
big fan you didn't need to dress up
Realignment how's it go and Jim let's go
I'm good buddy how's everything right
rich must hit himself in the face with
his headphones a few minutes ago and
Burke got excited by our room yeah
that's been the vibes early morning very
cool yeah yeah we roasted him last night
so we're all just kind of going over the
the attacks it was really a fun night
he's ever been a part of one of those a
celebrity roasts or anything like that
no no I haven't would you do that or do
you not really care to be made fun of
you know I fall somewhere in the middle
yeah you know I wouldn't say never but
I'm not wild about getting made fun of
constantly for hours we used to be
comfortable saying [ __ ] about people you
don't seem too shy about that at all you
seem comfortable being open I could
probably do a little that and I saw Jeff
Ross Don Rickles funeral service the
other day so you know he reminds me of a
roast yeah when I see him it grosses the
first where that comes in my mind I get
that yeah he felt like a really weird
industry I saw Jeff recently that's I
told like you're doing stuff no one does
like he goes to a prison and Rose people
he did he roasted the police yeah I mean
it really is ballsy the places he goes
and give me a lot more hair not too long
at one point he's gotten bizarre low and
that maybe something possibly no he did
it was stuck on his head it was his hair
and then he started losing it and then
one day just showed up bald and like it
looks like an experiment for Jakarta
because he did writing ILA's hair grow
out like crazy that would work in tennis
we'd say the challenge system we
challenged that that was his hair yeah
you got you got great hair loss by the
way your hair is stayed at the exact
same place the entire Rogaine work
pretty hearty well which kid is podcast
twice I use Rogan I have it in my bag oh
really usual day
yeah the priming helps yeah maybe it
does you don't lose any more yeah I'm
not sure I've gained a whole lot but you
know millet peach fuzz me up here do you
still you do actually is it I do what do
you do you rub it in are you
isn't lead don't drive no I don't know
what it does
she's sharing your bro Jane I don't you
let your hair hard for four hours
do you take it out that when they say
there if the if you have had erection
for four hours you immediately go
celebrate oh man have you ever had drink
do you take that stuff do you take any
until which one do you prefer I prefer
Rogaine cialis the only one else
oh you mean oh you know I haven't no I
haven't yet I have I like it all I talk
to you get addicted to them you start
like relying on Italian if I take it my
wife you know I go we in a section and
she says yes and I take it and then she
bails out on like look [ __ ] somebody's
paying for this [ __ ] pill cuz they're
like $40 apiece yeah why should at least
two twenties on yes charming guy this is
rich for interesting yeah that's just in
the way you put it on her yes but aliens
offense
you've got enough quoted a lot late you
got good pressure I guess I you know I
was I'm surprised you are you can
comment on Serena Williams you said that
she would be like number 700 in the
world if she played man were you just
kidding when you said that or he just
like not even trying to [ __ ] on her just
making a state I was just trying to be
honest even though I think Serena is
amazing and I think without Serena would
be in deeper [ __ ] than we are right now
we're like the game of tennis in America
it's not exactly killing it right it's
too unaffordable it's not accessible and
we need to get some personality and some
players and athletes the beth out
athletes playing basketball football
right lane and even you know the size of
a tennis court you probably have 20 kids
playing soccer so we're sort of the 1%
you know which is something I've always
wanted to change so with Serena and
Venus doing so great and coming from the
inner cities of LA Compton California
it's a great story I wish we could
capitalize on it more but having said
that for some reason people always seem
to talk about tennis with men and women
I'm not why don't they do that in
basketball they have WNBA we know what
where would that you know the star
players in the end nvm wmb how would
they do in the NBA right so it's not a
dish
it's they make it sound like it is but
you know I
believe there's a lot of you know what
about the hundred yard dash or boxing
you know I mean in boxing for example
they could have they could be at the
same weight class you know they'd both
be 160 power whatever path of the way
was so I have a solution though Jim the
solution is the men and women play
together and then well because this
we're all just guessing no one knows for
sure if Sarina played for two years
where would she be
I hope she'd be higher hopes he'd be 100
or 50 or whatever people believe that
she would actually big but there's a lot
of kids out there that people don't you
know college kids kids at my tennis
academy kids at other academies growing
up that can play a lot of kids that can
play and I think it's a little unfair
that sort of they've come at me again
why why is it always me she had a nice
little cross Federer up but ask him her
response was interesting because I
didn't think you were insanely horrible
she wrote Dear John I adore and respect
you but please please can we stop there
but please please keep me out of your
statements that are not factually based
I've never played any one ranked and
then she runs quotes there nor do I have
time respect me and my privacy as I'm
trying to have a baby
good day so like I didn't think the baby
thing like it's great but you said
babies you know I thought five times
I've been in the room with your watching
my kids be born and I know what an
amazing thing that is and I wouldn't
want anything by any means I don't want
to upset her but God forbid something I
wanted a baby to be healthy and happy so
if it felt a little like the end she was
sort of like hey don't get you know me
all stressed out which I felt bad about
if she actually even for one second
believes that but doesn't change whether
or not she can beat men at tennis no no
of course much she probably be more
difficult six months pregnant in my book
that were I'm supportive quite seriously
but my kids I four girls in two boys so
I've become a big believer in equal pay
and for the men and women I've changed
over the years back the fun I didn't
feel the same way when I was playing and
my girls look at me now you can't beat
Serena Williams so it's a topic that's
been talked about for 25
years ever since Serena and Venus came
out and said they thought they could
beat men Oh way back 20 years ago when
they first came on the scene and a guy
who was ranked like 250 300 in the world
went out and beat them in a practice
that they played each played a set and
so since then people now the President
of the United States of America you know
sent me an envelope but back in 2001 I
believe asking if I would play either
Williams sisters offered me a million
dollars to do that so would you say I
said that's a good start
yeah if we're going to do this if this
is as big as it is I would say first of
all I would donate my entire winnings to
charity and and and hopefully would be
something that would be interesting I
guess I don't know why again people find
this so fascinating I know it was
happening one time with Bobby Riggs and
Billie Jean King but you don't hear
about any other sports I think it's
interesting because you say things I
think it's interesting because you
always been the guy who kind of you know
you were very vocal and you were a
character and you were very unique in
tennis and the fact is that you're still
coming on just saying things how you
feel and that's kind of shocking the way
people are now nobody says what they
feel so it's kind it is just an opinion
yeah she's right it's not based on any
facts whatsoever other than that chief
you have to think okay what would she do
if she had a play solely against men why
don't we just combine it because we're
trying to figure out ways to make the
game more exciting at least temporarily
that would make it more interesting if
two women in the men play together the
most important part of the most exciting
part about watching the doll play is
watching his OCD super watch that eye I
do but I am a little distracted by the
fact you don't have a shirt on I am a
big tennis fan and I grew up playing
tennis of how much you obviously don't
play a hole watching the first fact I
had an Iranian regiment last often I'm a
karate saying for the records at Verdun
I don't want to go quite that far but
you could call it husky Albert is husky
according to John I was when I grew up
with small medium husky in Lawrence and
I was husky as a teenager so oh yeah I
eventually lost that baby fat that
apparently you still have there are some
websites yes one is frequent well they
tried in golf eh I think it was Michelle
Wie or somebody try to play on a boat or
is that a sport yes Golf is ten times
harder than ten I know I completely
agree with you
I completely agree no no no it is this
by far I've just started you know
getting somewhat addicted to it and it
is way more difficult and frustrating
makes Tennessee me like a walk in the
park but then again they don't run so I
sort of count sports that we actually
have to run to death yeah but it's not
I'm not saying it's not unbelievable
if Mackinaw says golf is complete [ __ ]
but you know I don't have a fork it's
not as I consider an art you know an
incredibly tough game and I and and I
it's it's definitely addicting I'm
trying to get better at it but I can no
it's a nightmare son you've been a part
of my used to work at the Tennis Center
I was a court attendant there all
through high school and one time maybe
2002 you're not making this up are you
no no I was I thought I was a high
school in Queens I'm from Queens
Brooklyn and I was I used to push the I
was pushing a full thing of Gatorade and
it hit a curb and all the Gatorade fell
out and I was with my best friend one of
my close friends Pat Finnegan and you
just were walking by and you just saw it
stop you went you dummy and and is that
in the book for the last 15 years of my
life like I'll just always get a random
text from my boy pad just like you dummy
and when I told you on the show wasn't
an insurer you dumbass or said you dummy
but I think we always love you about
something you would do yeah it was great
I'm in a nice way yeah no it wasn't what
about looking at more of a half-full and
sort of getting better perspective and
sort of being appreciative the fact that
I can even quote-unquote reinvent myself
so I know certain lemons and all I'll
say he broke down
from watching a tennis players from
being a court you know you see all the
tennis players you see all the
celebrities and some guys just walk by
don't sign autographs or just whatever
but you always stop and everybody always
loved you we always notice that we're
like uh John well the fan type well I
thank you I didn't I tried not to stop
for them because I say yes worthless and
enough you know and they're not worth
any time like please you don't want my
autograph you're not gonna get anything
another donation so now selfie hate them
right I'm not a big selfie guy I mean it
on me this is my kids want a selfie
that's a different Oriole young kid or
you me growing up and asking someone
were my idol rod laver copy of autograph
I mean that's cool but the you know the
seventy four-year-old or maybe this
because I'm big my biggest fan base is
women over 75 that I wouldn't mind
either but it's these guys that you feel
like you know they're selling it or
trying to and I try to tell me worth a
damn
yeah but that's that gets a bit much can
I talk about I was going to say you talk
about in the book that like used to Andy
Warhol mmm-hmm used to cock-block II
with his camera that you'd be at these
parties trying to you know pick up women
do what you do at a party and Andy
Warhol is running around with his camera
trying to photograph everybody and it
would just bug the [ __ ] out of yeah well
I got to got on my nerves I couldn't
figure out why this guy with this wig on
who did well as abnormal but um and when
you finally got to my friend's place I
won't mention names Richard Wiseman and
you thought you're okay you're free and
clear now no one's going to be you know
you can let your hair down a little bit
and you know whatever happens happens
and all of a sudden mr. Warhol would be
in there and it seemed like what is he
doing um he's just blowing my chance now
I can't blame him for my lack of success
totally but I say he contributed to it
he's a cautious he made me more cautious
and uptight and therefore my stick
wasn't working as well
we used to wrap it a couple of minutes
we only had John for a few minutes
though telling us I want you because
you're so honest in the book
now you reveal it your estranged from
your younger son Sean why are you guys
estranged how much time do we have about
five you know we're still in contact not
we're not totally estranged we haven't
seen a lot of each other for a while
but that's a long story and I hope to
god that we eventually have a tremendous
relationship how old he's 29 years old
you know and he part of it is you know
he's a firm believer and not wanting to
work a whole lot okay which I happened
to be hopefully I try to set by example
I mean he believes that he wants to be
an actor which is god bless him or he
wanted to be a musician or a
photographer now back to acting or
possibly writing a screenplay oh and
he's a talented kid
good-looking kid but I said look Jack
Nicholson this is he worked at a bar
till he was 30 you know shave the bills
you guys do that you go and do your set
when you're you know 20 years ago
whatever it was and you had to work at
times to make some cash not me just hand
it to them you know I want to help them
out and I've tried to help them out but
in essence that's you know I gotta pay
your dues I feel like you do and I think
you end up be having more character in
the end by sort of going through some of
those experiences especially if you're
trying to be an actor for example sure
do you think it's hard when you're when
you're when your parents are famous
they'd like you know for somebody
growing up like like my parents are both
icons what I've tried to obviously think
I've thought a lot about that and
obviously when your parents aren't
together and I've had a difficult time
since they've been divorced and seems
like getting undermined but if I do one
thing my ex does the other it or maybe
she you can have Tatum on and she could
tie the exact officer whatever it is but
this is my time now and it's difficult
even when you are together you know a
mother and we all know that as parents
and you all want what's best for your
kids but it's it's not easy when you're
sort of seeing things in a totally
different way and I've been lucky with
Patti Smith which is you know it's the
toughest job in the world being a
stepmom there's no question about that
and to sort of feel like we put in a
little time and effort and then feel
like how could you not you know see it
my way it's not easy but I got such a
crush on Tatum O'Neal you did oh you
have no [ __ ] idea I'm sure you had a
little available man
ah get her mind off me we have to wrap
we only had to take a quick break job I
love John McEnroe you really an honest
guy thanks for having me anytime man I
wish you'd remember yeah John's book
it's a follow-up to his bestseller they
feeling really waiting for this for a
long time it's called but seriously and
you know the this is after you cannot be
serious this is the follow-up and you're
just a brutally honest guy and III love
you so much so thank you for having an
thanks that would you you need to share
it or you're
[Laughter]